so i just pretty much knew like a lot of
the tattoos i was gonna get was gonna
mean something to me
i told my mama when i was like five
years old i told her when i get older i
want to have a lot of tattoos on the
grill
i lost my grill though it was subject it
was an early chop
and these are my tattoos it's good
[Music]
i don't even know i got three tattoos in
my first session
so first tattoo i got it got covered up
[Music]
i really got my own personal tattoo
man like he come tap me i'll drive like
two hours and come see me man
he's done most of them and he went over
like the ones that i got initially
[Music]
the ones on my arm i pretty much tried
to get my sleeve done
first this one here kyle it's the street
i was born
it's like a portion of me looking up
into like the heavy mix i don't want to
go to hell
i know i supposed to come here to serve
a purpose i gotta do one more tech right
here
but i didn't really thought it was not
yet so i just been leaving it but
i ain't really thought of no other one
ideas somebody told me to hit this one
yet i think i'm waiting
i ain't gonna set my face ain't no
follower i ain't got a reason to take my
face
in my face my favorite said to
i guess they probably just like pretty
much like i just got this one this is my
new
one and at least that's what no love
entertainment it's my brand
my lady it took like an hour and 30
prizes
two hours because it was mostly shaded
instead of just like
you know drawing it it was like a
shading person we looked through a lot
of flints before i picked the one i
wanted something bold there was
something
just stick out you know you see it clear
you know we ain't no curse over there
and at least that's with no love
entertainment it's my brand
my lady right here is the angel
behind my ear so they tell me the right
stuff
i got angels right here
i got angel numbers right here four four
four
and you serving a purpose you'll sin and
uh you don't know where you can miss
them like you keep saying a certain
number like
11 11
[Music]
recipes i got my dad
right here he's still with us and [ __ ]
just walked past
then i got my brother he back in memphis
and i got my mama again she she loved
this one right here
and then i got the broken heart right
here it's taking fast like
you're going through stuff but if you're
still growing and making it happen
signifies like being hurt
using y'all hurt his motherface still
just
still getting through stuff you know
this right here is to make it billy
cross
two-part here and then right here i got
marley i gotta smoke
as peacefully as possible look out
youtube peaceful
sitting right there recent people you
get it
top shadow right here because on the top
side
i got someone on the back of my leaves
the mom and cat
a lot of people don't touch the stomach
they scared against the stomach
and i uh i'm just going to tattoo i fell
to sleep
and he said man you super heal me don't
nobody fall asleep on the stomach tattoo
and i was just like man i said i
but at the end of the day all my texts
gotta mean something back to me
like the mommy gets on there don't mean
somebody
you gonna regret that tattoo so
i don't want that now i got al pacino
right now
scarface the one of my favorite games to
move and the world is yours
[Music]